في الحقيقه هذه الظروف الانسانيه الصعبه
يعيش فيها مئات والاف من النازحين هنا على
اطراف مدينه عفرين وهم الذين تضرروا
وفقدوا منازلهم في منطقه جنديرس والقرى
المحيطه فيها بالاضافه الى عدد من القرى
التي تضررت ودمر فيها منازل وتهدم فيها
ابنيه طابقيه في مناطق ريح حلب الشمالي
حقيقه الاوضاع الانسانيه كما نشاهدها هنا
خلفي تماما العائلات تفترش الارض تنتظر
مساعدات من المنظمات الانسانيه حقيقه
المساعدات نحن هنا منذ الصباح وحتى الان
لم نشاهد ايه منظمات انسانيه جاءت الى
المنطقه باستثناء فريق طبي ما زال حتى
الان في هنا بين يتفقد الاطفال يقوم
باجراء بعض الفحوصات للكبار في السن يقدم
بعض الادويه هم فريق تطوعي جاؤوا الى هذه
النقطه
للاطلاع على الواقع الطبي حتى هنا في هذه
النقطه هناك الاشخاص مصابون جراء الزلزال
وهم يقيمون في هذه النقط وسط الاوضاع
الانسانيه الصعبه خلفي تماما هنا هذه
الخيام هذه الخيام اقامتها وانشاتها بعض
المنظمات الانسانيه ولكن هذه الخيام لا
تكفي العدد الكبير من المتضررين نحن نتحدث
عن هذه النحو مئه خيمه ولكن في كل خيمه
هناك حوالي خمس او اربع او ثلاثه عائلات
في خيمه واحده ولكن من ينتظرون خارج هذه
الخيام ينتظرون
استجابه المنظمات الانسانيه هم كثر
نشاهدهم هنا بينهم النساء وجلهم من النساء
والاطفال
حتى انهم هناك التقينا في منهم اناسا
تحدثوا لنا عن فقدانهم
اذويهم فقدانهم افراد من عائلتهم بالاضافه
الى ان اعداد من اشخاص من افراد عائلاتهم
هم ما زالوا تحت الانقاض وفرق الدفاع
المدني تسعه على اخراجهم ينتظرون وصول جهه
امينهم ليتم دفنها حقيقه الواقع الانساني
صعب جدا استجابه من المنظمات ضعيفه جدا
ولكن الماساه كبيره نحن نتحدث عن منطقه
تمتد شارع ويمتد من مدينه عفرين حتى مدينه
جرس هو ممتلئ بالاهالي المتضررين الاهل
الذين يفترشون الطريق يمينا ويسارا
يفترشون الارض ويلتحفون السماء بلا سوى
فقط لديهم بعض الاغطيه وبعض الفرش وبعض
البطانيات التي يتدفؤون فيها ويكون
اولادهم البرد فيها يقومون بجمع بعض
الاخشاب وبعض اعواد الخشب من الاعراض
الزراعيه المحيطه في بهم ليقوم باحراقها
وتامين الدفع من خلالها حقيقه واقع صعب
جدا نقص في امكانيات حتى نقص في الخدمات
نحن هذه المنطقه هي مدرسه للتعليم القياده
تم انشاء فيها استثمار هذه المساحه من قبل
المنظمات محليه وانشاء فيها هذه الخيام
والعدد الممكن من الاهالي هذه المنطقه غير
مخدمه بالخدمات الاساسيه ان كان توفر
الماء او كان دورات المياه او المستلزم او
المطبخ متنقل ميداني او نقطه طبيه حقيقه
هذا النقص كبير جدا امام حاجه كبيره وملحه
جدا
التقينا بالفرق الانسانيه والفرقه الطوعيه
ومنظمات مجتمع المدني وذكروا لنا ان ابرز
احتياجات الاهالي في كل هذه المناطق وفي
كل هذه النقاط هي القيام والبطانيات
بالاضافه الى حليب الاطفال والادويه وما
امكن من مساعدات انسانيه غذائيه وحده
تنسيق الدعم قالت ان المتضررين يحتاجون
يوميا 55 الف وجبه غذائيه لتامينها وهي
صعب جدا التامين تامين هذا الكم الكبير من
المساعدات في ظل
العدد الكبير من
نحن نتحدث عن اكثر من 15 الف عائله متضرره
وفقدت منازلها او منازلها باتت غير صالحه
للسكن شكرا لك محمد الجزائري مراسل
الجزيره كنت معنا من ريف عفرين بريف حلب